Welcome everybody to another Zoom call. Let me take your questions and do our best to answer them.
Let's just jump right in.
Just for a binder, if you need to schedule a time with me, do please do that through the self-schedule.
We don't have as many staff as we used to and I need
to automate as many things as possible, so if you could do the self-schedule, that would help a lot.
Okay, first question, is there any benefit to hold your coffee at about beyond the 15 minutes?
If there's benefit to multiple coffee out of the city, why not, and hold it longer, while you
would be in trouble?
The answer that would be dull, not really, because you'll start to just absorb the coffee
and you'll just absorb the coffee in general, but fluid as well as the caffeine.
So, you've got beyond the stimulation, maybe you're just absorbing the fluid.
So, going beyond 15 minutes, no, so E2, is there a benefit to multiple coffee out of this
per day? Yes, and why not hold it longer if you're going to the trouble?
It's because the purpose of the coffee inhibitor is to stimulate the vagal nerve,
the parasympathetic radial nerve, tan, the vagus nerve.
So, vagal nerve stimulation is the whole purpose behind the coffee inhibitor.
Stimulating detox pathways, stimulate flushing of the liver, stimulate your bile,
motion, stimulate your immune function, calm you, all the benefits of parasympathetic stimulation.
So, doing it more often, yes, beneficial.
You have an excursions protocol, if you have people that are critically ill, do it five a day.
So, that's what you want to do.
Well, drinking greens first break a fast.
Well, technically, yes. So, drinking greens first, if you're doing a true fast, the answer is yes,
you would break a fast. Technically, if you're doing a true fast, you could only drink tea,
and technically not caffeinated tea. It has to be like an herbal flower blend or something.
That's really the only thing you could drink besides water if you're going to not break a fast.
And even some herbal teas can't technically break a fast.
So, you're truly doing just a water fast, that it has to be a water fast.
But it depends on what you're doing the fast for. If you're just trying to help your body clean out,
and you're on a time-restricted eating, and you're not eating your meal, tell three o'clock,
and your meal, your feeding time is three to six, or three to eight, or something like that.
Then don't worry about that. Then getting the nutrients is important.
It really depends on why you're doing a fast. So, if you're doing a fast
for reasons of just helping to heal your body, then I'd say, go ahead and take your supplements,
drink your greens, don't worry about breaking the fast or not following the rules of the fast.
If you're doing a fast to really reset your metabolism and lose weight,
and do a true water fast, then you can't drink greens for a stir protein,
drinks, or anything like that, or you can take your supplements because you're really truly
doing a water fast to lose weight. Now, there are such things as like a greens first.
There's not a ways to fast. So, fast means dividing yourself up something. That's all it means
is making a choice to eliminate something. You can fast, television, you can fast,
you know, junk food, you know, that those are all forms of thanks. But if you're talking about
you're doing a fast to reset your metabolism and lose weight, then you really want to be at a water
fast for that period of time. Now, I'll take the anything in. If you're doing it fast for the purpose
of just trying to get healthy, then, you know, you should take your supplements too.
Can I buy the individual components of the clear immune health? I'm trying to figure it out,
but some are sold by different names. Is there an upcharge for the convenience? So it might be
cheaper to buy them individually. You know, I don't know, I've never sat and figured out the math on it.
So, you can use, you know, you can do anything you want. Remember anything? I told you nutrition-wise,
that's what I'm recommending. You could do whatever you want. So, you know, if you don't want to take
the zinc that I recommend it, you have the exact same zinc by another brand.
Go buy all these. Take that. You have it. I hate to have you lay supplements. But, you know, how I
test you is with the supplements that I'm recommending. So, you are, you know, if it's the exact same
thing, you're taking that. Make these your malate by, you know, any company is going to be the same
maybe as your malate. But if you're taking, you know, a burberry by one company is not going to
be the same thing as a burberry by another company. A lot of supplement companies, especially
inexpensive supplements, are inexpensive because they're, they're watered down about water
repotting. There's, I told you before that there's, there's, when studies done, where they went to
Target and Walmart and, and it's the vitamin score I forgot. And they, a couple other store, when they
bought some Ashwagoda and some different, or most supplements. And they tested them in the, one that
tested best had like 10% of what was on the label. So, there's, there's just a lot of, you know,
bad stuff out there. There's, lots of times there's a reason why some things are less expensive
because they're not really what's on the label and they get by because nobody tests them.
So, if you're not getting it for a reputable company, you're just taking that chance.
Is the sale you currently have on the clear of you to pack $10 off the $99 price? No, I think it's,
that's, that's the price that's on there. So, the price is on there is the price.
That's the $10 off price. So, we've had the, at that, at that, for the last six months and
probably won't change that. How many drops in the, are in the lymph stem, the quested spinal?
I don't, I don't know how many ounces that is, but lymph still, I think a two ounce bottle has 300 drops.
Maybe it's a one ounce bottle has 300 drops. These are things you could Google. So, look up how many drops
in a one ounce bottle of the water or probably drops in a two ounce and look that up.
Lymph still is four ounces. So, there's at least 600 drops in there. So, that would last you a lot of time.
Based on my genetic testing, May 2023, Poe hydroxychabolomy was also today in phase two,
two per day were recommended. These are not, they do a supplement list. Are these no longer necessary for me?
So, when I test people, I'm testing them when I, what is on their cancer things, not on what is genetic.
So, the genetic thing isn't based upon, we make a recommendation based upon your genetics. It's not
based upon kinesiology testing. It's based upon what was on your genetics. So, it's a really good
question, but it needs clarification. I don't always add that to your thing. So,
what you were recommended to do for the genetic standpoint, you should always stay on that.
Really, and definitely, your genetics don't change. The genes don't get better. They only get worse.
So, yes, they can get worse. So, you read a new genetics that you maybe you read your genetics 10
years ago, and you read a new one, it could be different because you could have more defects. Why?
Because what causes defects? Well, you would hear it defects from your parents,
but you also acquire defects from your environment. So, if you're exposed to a toxin,
a.k.a. like chemotherapy, if you run your genetics post chemotherapy, it could be worse because toxins
affect your genes, and you could have damaged genes, and you could have worse genetics, that would not be
any close to being out of the question. So, recommendations are based on your genetics,
their based on your genetics, and those don't change. As per my recent updated chief stimulus,
you advised me to take micropoch 2 caps per day. Is this zeolite? So, micropoch, let me call it up,
is a zeolite product. It also has charcoal and has humic and phobic acid. It has a zeolite,
it has micro kytosan. A kytosan is a type of bentonite that stays, particularly stays in the gut,
it is a great binder in the gut. It has silica for a bad blue extract. You told me to continue to
take this zeolite that you have, this is what you have. Also, I have this already, the zeolite
for detoxing micro toxins. Zeolite is not solely for detoxing micro toxins. Zeolite is a
chelid, so it could chelid any metals, it could chelid all sorts of different things.
If I'm getting the mold and building eradicated from our house, how long should I take this?
So, you take what we could do it under cheek swab and we could test whether you still need it.
But we're not trying to... So, understand, I created a blog post, the different things that
mold, different problems that a person will have with mold exposure. So, with mold exposure,
you could have acute mold exposure to the phone guide itself, to the mold itself. So,
you breathe in the mold, you have that exposure to the mold. That is a pathogen that your immune
system will fire against to kill that pathogen. That could make a person sick for a period of time,
like Aspergillus. That's going to make a person sick. They have an acute immune reaction. They
fired immune TH1 reaction to kill that pathogen. It's a pathogen, a limit organism.
That is typically only in the acute phase. You're not going to have long standing typically
fungal infection in your body. The second issue that you have with mold exposure is the
Michael toxins. Not the mold itself, it's what the mold produces. So, Aspergillus and other molds
produce toxins. And we can breathe in those toxins. We can be exposed to those toxins through
different foods, most commonly it's through mold in the home of moldy building syndrome. Those
toxins are totally different than the living organism. So, the toxins are just like any other
toxins. It's not a living organism. It's not a canfire immune response, but the immune system will
do nothing with a toxin. Your immune system can't kill mercury. Your immune system can't kill lead.
Your immune system can't kill Michael toxins. Why? Because none of those things are lily.
Michael toxins like other toxins can settle in your tissues and cause damage. They can damage tissues
themselves. They are themselves oxidizing agents. They can damage cell membranes. If they go inside
the cell, they can damage the nucleus. They can be a cause of cancer. That's why on a microtoxin
test, you'll see that different types of microtoxins, like okras oscens, have been shown to cause cancer
to be cancer-causing agents. Well, the truth is, anything that gets inside the cell can disrupt the
nucleus of the cell and damage the DNA and cause it to go in rapid replication causing cancer.
So three different things that can be an issue with mold. I said the living organism. That's
typically only in the acute phase. Number two is Michael toxins. These are poisons that will stay in
your system indefinitely. You don't get them out. So zeolite is pulling out those. It's not
pulling out the mold. It's pulling out Michael toxins. Well, if I have acute mold, what would I take?
Well, you're most, I don't usually have to address that with cancer patients because you're
usually dealing with anything you're going to do to stimulate the immune system is going to help kill
mold. You're already on immune stimulators. But let's say somebody doesn't have cancer. They
contact me and acute aspergillis is their problem. Did I use something like phongoclear?
That is something that will help kill those things. Michael pole is to pull Michael toxins.
It doesn't specifically just do Michael toxins. It's going to help pull other toxins. No key
later is going to be specific totally to just Michael toxins. It's going to help pull other toxins
in heavy metals and all sorts of poisons out of your body. The third way that you're affected by
mold is if you're exposed to mold, you could end up creating antibodies to mold spores. These
are typically IgE antibodies. Those are the people that you know you have that. You're not even
to test for them because you know how to have it because those are people that are super sensitive
to any kind of mold. You might know somebody like that that oh my gosh, I can't go to that meeting
because when we needed that building at that school meeting, I just feel oh my gosh, I can just tell
can't you smell that? Oh my gosh, I got a headache. I don't feel good. You know, these people,
they're not crazy. They do have an IgE reaction to mold spores whereas their husband might be
going, what are you nuts? I don't smell anything. Don't you smell that mold? Oh my gosh, I got such a
headache. These people can be listed as a Cypocod reacts, but really they may have IgE antibodies to
mold spores. So when they spread them in their hypersensitive tool where they have a reaction that's
an IgE reaction, does the o-light remove other toxins for the body? I answered that.
So do you have any supplement sales or discounts coming up and do you share those ahead of time?
Well, I share them with you as soon as we get them. I don't we don't have any right now.
If ordering more than one bottle with the subscribe and save off checked, will the same number of
bottles be shipped or does it to fall back to one item? But when you subscribe to something you're
subscribing to individual products, we have people that subscribe to 20 different things. We have
people that subscribe to three things. We have people that make multiple script descriptions because
they have one subscription that they get every three weeks and another subscription they get every
six weeks with three other different things. So you have to kind of play that out. As the 5%
subscription discount apply to sale or discounted products as well. And typically it depends. I think
if we do have fire sales all the time and that has to do with products that are put on fire sale
because they're at expiration date. I understand the product and expiration date.
The expiration date and the products are put there because the FDA requires it.
But the truth is there's a lot of products that literally never expire. A mineral,
multiminus or something like that, magnesium, zinc, that will never ever expire.
Products that are antioxidants are never going to expire. I'll give you an example. One company
that we used tested a product that they had in their warehouse that one of the CEOs was
holding because it was one of the first products they ever made back in like 1970 or 1965 or something.
So they thought, well, this would be fun. Let's let's send a few of these to the lab to see how they
test. It tested at 90% of its listed capacity after like 50 years. And the reason is it's because it
had antioxidants in it. So if anything that has antioxidants in it, it's literally going to
forever shelf life. So don't throw out those supplements that have antioxidants in it.
So, but we can't really sell them once they reach expiration. So we put them on discounted,
heavily discounted, and those you cannot do a subscription on those because those are a limited
double. We might only have five or something or two or something. What I know, what I know,
one month subscription plan, will the supplements be shipped so as not to interrupt daily consumption?
What do you have put in a subscription? And let's say you do it on the fifth of February and it's
on a one month every the fifth of every month. It's going to produce in our store and it
comes up in the store as a subscription. But then we fill it. So if you want it before that,
then you have to tell you that you have to figure out the timing of that. So we fill it automatically
populates. So that's what our system does. So it will automatically populate when you how you create
that subscription. So if you have some things that you need every 30 days and then you have other
things that you need every 45 days, you might want to create multiple subscriptions based upon that.
Well, I need this every 30 days, but I only need this every 60 days. So you'll have to create, you know,
maybe you have three things that you need every 60 days, two things you need every 30 days,
well, you're going to have two subscriptions then. What it will be for the world you need every 30
days will be that, or you could have one subscription, but you'll get two models of this and one
model of that. That's something you're going to have to figure out. We don't really have the staff to
do that. So please do your math, figure out your math. Do internal parasites quickly become immune to
iburectin or fed bed. I'm going to take you to iburectin for quite a while, about three modes,
switch to paste, do not know the city improvement or proxy. Well, the fed bed and iburectin as far
as parasite killers are, hold on one second. Oh yeah, also Megan said with the subscription thing
here, you have to factor in shipping too. So just remember that, you know, so wherever you are,
when we will typically fill the order or the day it comes in. But if you set this up on a Friday,
afternoon, you're not, it's not going to get filled till next Monday. Because our hours are
typically close at two to 30 on a Friday, it's not going to get filled till next Monday. And then
it's going to take several days to get there. So you're going to have to do that. You have to figure
that out too. It's best to clean ahead as much as possible. As far as internal parasites become
the new to iburectin and fed bed, I would, I would say I don't think that that happens. I would
caution you against thinking that all your problems are from parasites. So, um,
um, yes, people can have parasites. I remember back to the fed bed, do kill parasites, but they kill
specific parasites, mainly parasites that are really intestinal. Some that might be in the liver with
liver floats, but they're not going to kill what a parasite might have done to a person. So let me give
you an example. It's very common with people with Lyme disease that they may have been diagnosed with
Lyme disease 10 years ago, let's say. And they still have symptoms that they're blaming it on the
Lyme disease still. Well, of course, I got this all and I got ticked by 10 years ago. I've never
been the same sense. Okay, so let's differentiate whether our symptoms are from a current infection
or from the effects of a past infection. Really hard to get people to understand this, especially
in these Lyme groups on Facebook and all this stuff, everything is blamed on this disease,
just like you can blame everything on parasites or blame everything on whatever, okay.
We have to understand physiology. 99% of the time your body will take care of things,
your immune system will kill things, especially if you ate it like in the case of a parasite,
which is a multi-celled organism. So it's very, it's much more difficult for your immune system
to kill. If you take agro-metry and fed-bed, it's a parasite killing nutritional things,
you can kill the parasite. But then why do I still have problems now? X amount of bugs,
X amount of years later, because a parasite, just like a bacteria like Borrelia,
Borgidorphia that causes Lyme disease, could be long gone. Years and years, a decade ago,
it's dead. It's not even in your body anymore, but it did damage. It went
into a cellular, your immune system tried to kill it into a cellular, started to make antibodies
against different cell tissue lines. And now you have cell tissue antibodies. You guys,
if you're really interested in stuff, you've got to go on our autoimmune,
chronic disease and autoimmune module and start watching some of those videos.
Because that's how you're going to learn about this stuff. You're not going to fight it on
Instagram and Facebook. So you have to understand that most people that think that they have parasites
after they've done a ton of different parasite cleanses, or think that they have Lyme disease,
or think that they have this constant virus that they're trying to kill and just can't kill Lyme
disease. I can't figure out why I can't try to kill Lyme disease. I got this flare again.
I'm not discalculating their symptoms. I'm saying what are they really from? We're not from the
organism still present. They're from, because they're living the organism was there in a specific
time in your life, it doesn't mean it's still there, but it doesn't mean it didn't do damage. So you
could have all sorts of things from it. You could have microgloclimates, you could have autoimmune
formation, meaning your body created immune antibodies against cell tissue. And that's really
what your symptoms of your flares are from. You need to go onto that course and learn that stuff
for you and your loved ones, because that's a big reason why a person has chronic
comorbidities. Now when you're dealing with cancer, you're made focus on killing cancer.
Once you eat a state of remission, now you're going to start focusing on what else could I do to
deal with these other symptoms I have in my body? Well, you've got to figure out what it is and
what you need to, what they actually are. So running some antibody tests can be beneficial,
but just because a person has cancer, doesn't mean they don't have comorbidities of autoimmune
disease. That's why I created that whole course for you guys to learn that. So go start to get into
that. Are you familiar with acrobidation, which is a probiotic? Yes, a friend ran across it as a
probiotic and that it said to help us side effects of recovery of ketruna, if you don't therapy.
I had three rounds of ketruna with people last one in early November. My side effects were itchy
rashes skin. Now, and now Hashimoto's, I'm wondering if my gloomy, distended belly could be from the
ketruna or an extension of ketruna and Hashimoto's. So when you have ketruna, so ketruna is the
neotherapy that blocks the PD1 receptor, which is the receptor that tells on T cells that tells them
not to attack self-tition. Well, when you take a drug that blocks that, now we start attacking
self-tissues. The side effect of ketruna and other immunotherapy drugs is that you could end up with
an autoimmune disease. Now, once you have an autoimmune disease, you have cell antibodies. That's
what autoimmune disease is. Go back to that course and start learning that. Can you take this probiotic
and see if that helps? What's your gut? Sure. You can change and I recommend that you change up
to a regular basis. You prescribe the microtox, even though I have a zero line. Yes, because that's
what tested on you. And the microtox is other things than just the ZN like that you have. So you can take
that. If you order five of something, other subscription, you're subscription remains for five of
that thing. Correct. That's right. So Megan is the shipping team. That's right. She has. So if you do
order five of something, you know, you're going to get five, either five different products or five
one product. You're going to get that every month or every two weeks or every six weeks or whatever
you set up that subscription. So make sure you don't do that. Because if you accidentally mess that
up and you get multiple things that you don't need in order for you to send that back, we have to
charge a restocking fee. And technically, if it's in somebody's house and it's, if it's open,
you can't get anything back at all. So I mean, you just please be careful and and sit out and writing
out what you need to do with that. Also, is your life technically a binder and will it bind to
other minerals and things in my body? Should we be taking it away from food and other supplements?
I mean, which is taking any key later? So my definition that between a key later and a binder is
the binder stays in your gut, my key later is absorbed. Now, there's a lot of things that act as
binders in your gut and will cross the gut border and act as key later in your tissue. So is it better
to take all key laders slash binders away from food? Well, in a perfect world, yes.
And away from other supplements get a perfect world, yes. Is it always necessary? Is it always
realistic? No. But yeah, in a perfect world, it'll be better to take all key laders and all binders
away from other food. Sometimes it's a very difficult particular. So I don't always state that,
or do state and all the binders that are state in your gut to take those away from food.
I just watched one of your videos on glutamates. So this is fun. I use to really like Doritos.
Why? Because they have MSG, or glutamate unit to tell your brain that you're loving.
So at Christmas, I had a couple of Jubilee days and it was very exciting about Doritos. Another
junk food. I used to really like and splurge on pre-canceling. I used to splurge on pre-canceling.
It was such a letdown in a fabulous way to no longer like the junk food, including Doritos.
Oh, that's great that you didn't like it because most people instantly it's going to fire or
glutamate reaction to the brain. So it's great to do. You know, there's other options out there. There's a,
that's not Caliol brand that, that's a family created, Ciette. Ciette brand. There's a Ciette brand
chip that has no MSG, nothing in it. That is, and they have a flavor that's very similar to
Ciette. Doritos, you should try that. It's very good. I was reading that, too, for it,
is a phyto estrogen. I take quite a bit. Both you and my local practitioner have also tested
the audit and said it was good to me. Should I worry about it? Since my breast cancer was
ER-positive and I'm not taking the whole amount of drugs. Although I would worry about it,
it tested well for you. Now, if you do want to really make sure your levels are at a good level,
run the Dutch test. So if you have any concern of exposure to exogenous estrogens in any form,
which we're all exposed to exogenous estrogens, run the Dutch test and see if, you know,
where your estrogen levels are at. That's a good thing to do. So yeah, the Ciette brand, they're all
really good chips. So that could be a substitute for the curts of an est. How far away from
other supplements should the zero life be taken? So typically, you say 30 minutes away from other
supplements. But the truth is, it's a hard game to play because it depends on how fast or
testicles transit time is, you know? It depends on how much food you have in regard. Well,
I haven't eaten for 30 minutes. Well, it depends on how much was there. So there's a lot of
things, a lot of unknowns there. But typically, you say 30 to 60 minutes away from food
and other supplements is the safest way to do. I wish the Ciette brand was organic. Tell me about it.
So many of the paleo things, the gluten-free things are not organic. And you have to argue that,
if it's not organic, you know, how good is it for you to do? So now there's a lot of things now
that are gluten-free, but they're not GMO. They do have other promises on their label. But there's a lot
of gluten-free stuff out there, because most of that family is gluten-free. That is not GMO. Well,
that's terrible for you. The stuff is garbage. And it's very frustrating. Then just go back to growing
your all-year-old food and feed all your own food that you grow. You're learning how to care,
you're learning how to freeze your eye, you're learning how to be hydrate, and learning how to put
needles in and learn how to do all that stuff. It's difficult. It's to be okay, for sure.
My gluten stomach be from Hashimoto or something else that should have probiotic help.
Well, probiotic isn't going to help Hashimoto. So if you have Hashimoto's, you also have to
make sure, absolutely, positively, that you are gluten-free. So gluten is a molecular,
mimic, cross-reactant to side of our unit. So you cannot eat gluten. So again, go to the
Autolean course, I have an entire module on Hashimoto's. So make sure you look at them,
you haven't. But if you're eating gluten, dairy can be a cross-reactant to gluten.
You're eating gluten and dairy with Hashimoto. If you do anything's game, I mean, that could be it.
Also, consider doing a Cyrex 10 if you have bloating. If you're not taking, if you're already taking
HCL with digestive enzymes, consider upping that for a period of time. If doing a Cyrex 10 is out of
financial consideration, so all those things to think about with Hashimoto's.
Hashimoto's in itself is not going to cause bloating. But comorbidities that go along with Hashimoto's,
which are food sensitivities, gluten, definitely cross-reactant inflammation,
creating antibodies to gluten and dairy are all causes of bloating and grain fog,
great inflammation. So be careful of all of those things. Not eating dairy or gluten or sugar
to have it in quite a while, except for a bunch of bleak eggs. So getting tested for cross-reactant
foods might be something you want to look at too. So if a person is like, I have Hashimoto's, and I
would gluten free and dairy free for years, and I'm still having these issues, while you could have
other issues with other foods. So anything, so you have autoimmune,
when you have antibodies to your self tissue, anything that's going to cause inflammation,
it's going to cause your immune system to get worse. That's the problem when you have cancer.
So if you have cancer, you have to be stimulating your immune system to kill the cancer,
but every time you're stimulating your immune system, you're affecting your autoimmunity.
So it's a catch-22, but it's like, okay, well, I'm going to deal with these symptoms of
Hashimoto's and kill my cancer, or am I going to succumb to cancer and have less Hashimoto's symptoms.
So let's you have to play with that balance. The other praise is that my memory and
day grade clock were getting better, been doing salarriages for two weeks, might be bad,
the movements come with salarriages, well, I'm sure the care of anything you're doing is good,
you're decreasing inflammation, so that's good. All right, we are going to close for the night,
thanks for being out, I'll be praying for you all, and I'll talk to you guys next week.